hi I'm Chloe a developer advocate for
Google cloud and in this video I'll walk
you through how you can use assured
workloads to support your data residency
and other compliance and security
requirements in Australia
[Music]
Google Cloud customers use assured
workloads to help protect the sensitive
data they store and process on Google
Cloud
assured workloads enforces security
controls and guard rails needed to
protect infrastructure while maintaining
compliance
for customers who wish to establish
Australian data residency customers can
specify the Google Cloud regions in
Australia where their data will be
stored and ensure that it will remain
there
assured workloads implements a Google
Cloud platform organization policy that
restricts customer data to being stored
in a specific region customers can
choose from the current cloud regions in
Australia Melbourne and Sydney this is
coupled with our new assured support
service which means that customer
support will be provided from only five
countries United States Australia Canada
New Zealand and the United Kingdom
this ensures that only Personnel in one
of those locations are allowed to
provide support to a regulated customer
in Australia
this control also restricts access to
customer data to individuals who meet
this requirement during the resolution
of a customer initiated support case
through assured workloads controls
support meets the requirements of the
Australian government's information
security registered assessors program
and the hosting certification framework
which is administered by the Australian
government's digital transformation
agency
let's take a closer look on how to get
started with assured workloads for
Australia first visit the Google Cloud
console at cloud.google.com console
before you can set up an assured
workloads environment you must select an
organization
then navigate to the compliance section
in the compliance section you will have
to create a new assured workloads folder
or use an existing assured workloads
folder within your organization's Cloud
hierarchy
for each existing folder you can see its
name creation time compliance type data
region and labels
click create to create a new assured
workloads folder you will first need to
check that you meet the prerequisites
for folder creation this means having
access transparency enabled for your
organization
this provides you an audit trail of
support actions
a premium subscription to assured
workloads
this is required for assured workloads
for Australia next select the geographic
area in which you aim to meet data
residency requirements
assured workloads offers control in
Australia but also in the EU the US and
Canada as of today
let's pick Australia
as you can see assured support provides
customers 24 7 access to Google Cloud
technical support from five specific
countries United States Canada Australia
United Kingdom and New Zealand
support is provided in the English
language it sets data location controls
to available Australia regions let's
pick Australia regions with assured
support and click next specify the
Australia region you would like to
restrict your workload to select
australia-southeast one which
corresponds to the Sydney region and
click next
select the parent folder you registered
earlier as the place where your new
folder will live
then give your assured workloads folder
a name
and click next
the last step is configuring your key
management project in key ring this will
create a separate Key Management project
within your assured workloads folder and
a key ring in which to place your keys
the key ring sets you up to utilize
customer managed encryption keys or
externally managed encryption keys
click next this brings you to the review
section where you can review compliance
type details folder name and location as
well as supported products
click create to create the assured
workloads folder
now you will see the new assured
workloads folder in your list from this
point forward any folder or project
created inside of this folder will
inherit the guardrails you specified
now that your folder is created you are
able to set up encryption keys
you'll see the encryption section which
shows you information about the separate
Key Management project created for you
click on the project name to open it
when entering a project inside the
assured workloads regulatory boundary
customers are presented with a
regulatory intercept that warns them
about entering sensitive data in the
environment and logs their
acknowledgment and access to the project
now let's take a look at how you can
create a cloud resource within your
assured workloads folder
create a new project within the assured
workloads folder you created earlier
make sure to set the location
appropriately
once your project is created select it
and acknowledge the compliance agreement
navigate to the cloud storage section of
the console click create bucket
give your bucket a name
select the default options for location
storage class and access control
as you can see we have several options
to store our data we can select from
different multi-region options however
because of the data residency controls
we set previously this should not
succeed we'll create this bucket and
ensure that we're enforcing Public
Access prevention this alert lets us
know that it is blocking our ability to
deploy this bucket in the United States
since it violates the constraints for
the resource location
in other words only a valid region would
be a valid selection
so if we select the correct dual region
you'll see that we're able to create a
bucket in a location that aligns with
our data residency requirements that we
specified when we first created the
assured workloads folder
at this point any files or objects
uploaded to this bucket and their
resources will be located in the Sydney
region
all the currently supported services and
assured workloads are listed in our
documentation under supported products
see our Link in the description to stay
current on what's new as we're adding
more services regularly
so there you have it a walkthrough of
how you can get started with assured
workloads in Australia to easily deploy
supplementary data protection measures
for workloads on Google Cloud to learn
more visit
cloud.google.com assured Dash workloads
take a look at the description on this
video for more assured workloads
resources and to see videos on how to
build cloud workloads with compliance in
mind thanks for watching
thank you
[Music]